[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat et de
reportage sur Public Sénat 90 minutes et
deux grands thèmes notre promesse est de
donner du temps à nos experts pour
donner du sens à l'actualité voici le
sommaire de ce 7 février qui marque la
troisième journée de mobilisation contre
la réforme des retraites moins de
grévistes moins de manifestants mais
peut-on pour autant parler d'un
essoufflement du mouvement quelle est la
stratégie de l'Inter syndicale pour les
jours et les semaines à venir comment le
combat parlementaire influe sur la
mobilisation et vice-versa réponse dans
une minute et puis pour notre second
débat volontairement décalé de
l'actualité du jour direction Mayotte
dans l'océan Indien le sang unieme
département français fait face depuis
des mois un mélange de violence
d'insécurité d'immigration à contrôler
sur fond d'extrême pauvreté
on est en train nous à Mayotte de subir
une crise qui était annoncée
on ne peut plus entendre c'est pas moi
c'est le maire c'est pas moi c'est le
conseil départemental c'est pas moi
c'est l'état c'est pas moi c'est la
police c'est pas moi c'est la
gendarmerie la réponse répressive du
gouvernement est-elle suffisante les
immigrés clandestins venus des Comores
sont-ils les seules responsables de ces
violences réponse dans 45 minutes avec
ce chiffre en tête à Mayotte au second
tour de la présidentielle c'est Marine
Le Pen qui est arrivé en première
position avec 60% des suffrages mais
d'abord donc la réforme des retraites
combattues dans la rue par des centaines
de milliers de Français encore
aujourd'hui on retrouve tout de suite
Quentin Calmet qui est avec nous sur le
parcours de la manifestation parisienne
place de la République
bienvenue Quentin des éléments beaucoup
de réactions et puis évidemment quelques
chiffres que l'on attend
[Applaudissements]
oui tout à fait Thomas avec des
syndicats qui parlent toujours lui de
mobilisation importante voire très
importante selon les centrales des
chiffres similaires à la première
journée de mobilisation celle du 19
janvier alors qu'il y a une deuxième
manifestation cette semaine elle sera
samedi et qu'une partie des français est
en vacances scolaires écoutez le constat
de Frédéric Souillot le secrétaire
général de Force Ouvrière aujourd'hui la
mobilisation elle est pleine et entières
alors un petit peu en dessous de ce qui
était le 31 mais tout le monde sait
qu'on a deux journées de mobilisation
cette semaine y compris samedi j'ai le
retour de Reims encore aujourd'hui 10000
manifestants
10000 au Puy-en-Velay ils étaient 11000
la semaine dernière donc la mobilisation
elle est pleine et entières et quand on
fera les comptes à la fin de la semaine
on sera plus nombreux que le 31 voilà
des mobilisations qui peuvent peser sur
les débats parlementaires qui se
tiennent en ce moment même dans cycle de
l'Assemblée nationale c'est ce que dit
en tout cas le secrétaire général de la
stgt Philippe Martinez écoutez-le la
mobilisation elle pèse y compris sur les
députés de la majorité des députés de
droite parce que je pense que c'est une
réalité de la démocratie quand on est
élu on n'a pas un blanc simple pendant 5
ans pour faire ce qu'on veut alors que
se passera-t-il si elle exécutif
n'écoute pas c'est mobilisations et bien
là Philippe Martinez averti il faudra
alors passer un cran au-dessus le climat
va alors se tendre et les grèves vont se
durcir c'est ce que nous a dit le leader
de la CGT à la FSU le syndicat où il y a
beaucoup d'enseignants on alerte aussi
sur un ton solennel écouter Benoît test
car aujourd'hui un problème démocratique
de fond dans ce pays avec une démocratie
sociale qui s'exprime aujourd'hui de
manière unanime et très forte et il faut
entendre ce message sinon c'est le c'est
pas la réforme au locao c'est l'écoute
de ce qui se passe ou alors c'est le
basculement vers l'inconnu et vers
quelque chose d'extrêmement dangereux
pour le pays voilà prochain rendez-vous
avec la mobilisation de samedi des
syndicats qui appelle time mobilisation
des manifestations à la fois familiales
et populaire Thomas merci Quentin merci
également à Yann et FEDER romain Ferrier
qui vous accompagnent sur cette
manifestation parisienne je vous propose
de découvrir d'accueillir mes invités
leurs salvats bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes directrice générale de cantar
publique Jean-Marie Pernaut bonsoir
bienvenue politologue chercher à
l'Institut de recherche économique et
social et je cite votre livre le
syndicalisme d'après aux éditions du
détour Benjamin Morel bonsoir Benjamin
bienvenue vous êtes constitutionnaliste
et mettre le conférence en droit public
à Paris de Panthéon Assas Mathieu
croissanto qui est là mardi pour une
fois bonsoir Mathieu bienvenue à vous et
politique on va j'ai trouvé que s'il y a
toujours des messages à aller chercher
dans les réactions comme ça officiel des
leaders syndicaux dans une manifestation
on va on va reprendre certains des des
propos des uns et des autres camps quand
Frédéric Souillot le secrétaire général
de Force Ouvrière finalement anticipe la
grève de samedi enfin les manifestations
de samedi la grève de demain etc
mouvement qui ne s'essouffle pas est-ce
que c'est ce que vous voyez vous aussi
dans l'opinion c'est vrai qu'il faut
tenir sur le temps long puisque nous
aurons des des débats et finalement
comment dire une validation de ce projet
ou pas le 26 mars donc il y a cette cet
enjeu de tenir sur le sur le long terme
ce que nous voyons nous dans les données
d'opinion c'est effectivement une très
grande stabilité de l'opinion à la fois
sur le rejet de cette réforme puisque
majoritairement les Français rejettent
cette réforme il soutiennent aussi
majoritairement les la mobilisation qui
a lieu contre contre la réforme de la
même façon aujourd'hui comme hier ils
ont toujours le sentiment que les
objectifs de cette réforme ne sont pas
claires et je pense que ça fait partie
aussi un peu du péché originel du
gouvernement c'est-à-dire finalement de
pas avoir su convaincre sur l'objectif
et l'urgence de la de la réforme on
parle beaucoup de pédagogie aujourd'hui
je pense que la réforme n'est pas
compliquée à comprendre c'est recul de
l'âge légal à 64 ans notamment avec
d'autres mesures aussi effectivement
c'est surtout ce que l'on retient les
analyses c'est surtout ce que l'on
retient mais c'est pas si compliqué que
ça je pense que ce qui est compliqué à
comprendre pour les Français c'est
pourquoi le gouvernement a voulu mettre
en place cette réforme aujourd'hui et ça
ça n'a pas bougé et la même façon je
trouve que dans ce que nous disent les
Français il n'y a pas non plus
d'opposition très convaincante quand on
leur demande qui est convaincant sur le
sujet en matière d'opposition à la
réforme bien les scores ne sont pas ne
sont pas très élevés et finalement ceux
en qui on a le plus confiance
aujourd'hui ça reste les syndicats mais
à des niveaux assez faibles quand même
dans l'opinion alors cette impression
peut-être d'une situation figée en ce
mardi on va évidemment beaucoup parler
de dans ce débat j'en aurais Pernot la
stratégie on l'a entendu la stratégie de
l'intersyndicale évidemment c'est c'est
de durer de tenir notamment le temps des
débats parlementaires mais faire grève
ça coûte cher et en temps d'inflation ça
c'est un argument d'autant plus
important il y a là une équation
peut-être particulièrement compliquée à
tenir c'est une équation classique des
grèves mais encore plus en temps
d'inflation oui bien sûr ça l'enjeu de
l'enjeu en fait c'est aussi la grève
quoi dans ces conflits là parce que dans
les conflits qui ne mobilisent qu'à
travers les manifestations de rue le
pouvoir politique fait un peu le gros
dos il a donc ça se calme le patronat
dit rien parce que ça n'affecte pas
l'activité économique donc on a vu des
grandes séquences comme ça avec des
millions de gens ou brassés dans la rue
comme en 2010 et où finalement c'était
que quelques mauvais moments à passer
par contre si la grève s'installe ce qui
avait été le cas en 95 le les
manifestations étaient corrélés à un
haut taux de grévistes ce qui est plus
le cas aujourd'hui et là il arrive à
avoir une déconnexion baisse du taux de
grévistes entre on peut avoir des
manifestations très puissantes et
supporté par un mouvement tournevis
c'est assez faible les gens ils viennent
ils débrayent alors ça on n'arrive pas à
chiffrer ça parce qu'en fait il y a des
sur Paris c'est impossible à voir mais
dans certaines villes de province c'est
plus de faire notamment dans les petites
c'est plus facile de voir que il y a
quand même pas mal d'ouvriers employés
qui ont fait des débrayages c'est pas
comptabilisé on met en réalité on sait
bon c'est pas très bien quel est
l'ampleur du mouvement d'arrêt de
travail mais c'est un enjeu de sur la
durée du conflit parce que effectivement
il mise sur les manifestations en fait
c'est pas toujours les mêmes qui
viennent aux manifester de même que
c'est pas toujours les mêmes qui font
grève parce que de faire grève deux fois
de suite sur le même mois en ce moment
en particulier c'est c'est compliqué
mais donc il y en a qui ont fait grève
la semaine dernière pas grève là et
inversement et c'est pareil dans la
participation manifestation on avait
constaté ça en 2010 c'était pas les
mêmes qui venaient il y avait un espèce
de brassage donc même s'il y avait que
un million cinq ou deux millions de gens
à un moment donné s'il y a toujours 2
millions la semaine d'après c'est pas
forcément les mêmes on voit que ça
engage des gens là le pari des syndicats
c'est de le faire samedi pour essayer
d'en faire autre chose que simplement
arrêt de travail essayer d'en faire
quelque chose de populaire comme ils
disent faire venir les familles etc bon
et même avec si on fait un focus sur les
syndicats de la SNCF le fait de décider
de ne pas faire grève pendant les
vacances scolaires qui évidemment aussi
un message envoyé à l'opinion c'est tout
tout ça n'est pas notre je pense qu'on y
reviendra je vais reprendre des propos
de Philippe Martinez maintenant quand il
dit la mobilisation pèse y compris sur
les députés de la majorité les députés
de droite Benjamin Morel les
parlementaires c'est une évidence de le
dire mais ils rendent des comptes à
leurs électeurs et donc je parlais dans
mes titres de
ces vases communicants entre les
manifestations la mobilisation et les
débats au Parlement le les a influent
sur l'autre et vice versa c'est tout
l'objectif en réalité quand vous prenez
les grandes réformes sociales qui ont à
chopé il y a toujours un volet
parlementaire parce que infini si vous
avez une majorité pour voter votre
réforme vous savez ou si la majorité ne
tremble pas sur ces bases et bien votre
effort elle finit par passer donc
l'objectif à la fois de l'opposition on
y reviendra peut-être qui fait
l'obstruction massive et de l'autre côté
des syndicats qui manifestent c'est de
faire douter la majorité parce que quel
va être le coup politique de cette
réforme moi député ensemble est-ce que
lorsque je me représenterai en 2027
voire même lors d'une dissolution on me
dit qu'elle pourrait arriver est-ce que
mes électeurs vont m'en vouloir moi
député LR est-ce que j'ai intérêt à
soutenir cette réforme sachant que là
aussi j'ai une partie de ma base qui est
en train de me dire de ne pas y aller si
jamais vous commencez à avoir un doute
qui s'instille et bien tout d'un coup
vos amendements ils vont peut-être
passer si vous commencez à avoir un
doute qui s'instille votre réforme elle
peut potentiellement être rejetée et
c'est ça que craint évidemment un
gouvernement et c'est pour ça que du
côté de l'opposition comme du côté des
syndicats et bien le jeu parlementaire
est en réalité le cœur névralgique même
si après mais il s'agit de montrer que
vous avez l'opinion avec vous il s'agit
de montrer que vous avez le peuple avec
vous quand il manifeste il s'agit de
montrer que vous avez une capacité de
blocage mais tout ça au fond bah c'est
pour faire douter un autre élément cette
phrase de Benoît test secrétaire général
de l'effet su qui dit on a un problème
démocratique qui me font dans ce pays en
fait leur Salvat sont deux légitimités
qui s'opposent
Philippe Martinez le disait le disait
aussi un mandat c'est pas 50 blancs ça
et celle d'Emmanuel Macron elle est
peut-être plus ancienne et un peu plus
fragile de légitimité effectivement mais
je crois qu'en effet les Français il
réagissent pas comme ça c'est-à-dire
c'est pas parce qu'Emmanuel Macron a été
élu en effet qui est que on s'attend à
ce que ils mettent en place absolument
tous en compromis sans discussion je
crois que justement ce qu'on voulut
exprimer les Français notamment au
travers des élections législatives on
l'a bien vu c'est justement cette
peut-être culture du compromis du débat
de
comment dire de la discussion aussi et
c'est au sein des parlements
effectivement qui l'attendent cette
cette discussion pour que on puisse
mettre en place et ça je pense que les
hommes politiques et les femmes
politiques aujourd'hui ont un peu de mal
en effet à avancer vers ce modèle là
vers un modèle beaucoup plus justement
de de
compromis au sein même de leur propre
majorité et pourquoi pas de faire un pas
vers une
majorités du premier jour de débat le
premier jour hier et aujourd'hui à
l'Assemblée c'est pas exactement mais
voilà ça tombe le compromis d'accord le
problème alors même que c'est
effectivement ce qu'attendais les
Français moi je suis toujours partagé
quand j'entends que les Français ont
fait le choix du compromis c'est vrai
que le résultat de l'Assemblée donne
plutôt ce ça c'est une obligation une
nécessité de compromis pour se mettre
d'accord mais je pense que les Français
ont quand même voté pour des choix
politiques ou idéologiques qui pour le
coup était beaucoup plus dans
l'antagoniste dans le compromis les gens
ils ont voté RN où ils ont voté l'UPS ou
ils ont voté Macron et quand on a voté
Macron c'est souvent contre le RN ou la
nups et quand on a votéupestre c'est
contre Macron donc je suis pas certain
qu'il y a eu dans le choix des Français
au moment de glisser le bulletin dans
l'urne au législatif une volonté de
compromis après c'est vrai que pour
gouverner cette assemblée est réputé un
gouvernable mais il faut être capable de
discuter et le gouvernement n'a pas su
le faire sur ce dossier là du tout au
delà des grands discours des événements
qui appelaient à la concertation elle
n'a pas su le faire la concertation
sociale avec les syndicale n'a pas su
faire une forme de concertation
suffisante avec les parlementaires il se
trouve que les pas aidé parce que elle
est avec elle avait commencé le dialogue
fait monter les enchères mais
mais je suis pas certain non plus que
les oppositions étaient prêtes à
discuter de ce sujet là sur ces bases là
ils sont même pas d'accord quand on
regarde on trouve le gouvernement et les
oppositions sur le diagnostic et sur la
nécessité de faire cette réforme on
attitré ce débat l'impasse est-ce que
vous avez moi je disais un petit
sentiment d'immobilisme est-ce que vous
avez ce sentiment oh une impasse je suis
pas sûr enfin politiquement ça peut se
discuter mais là on est sur un chemin le
mouvement social il acquiert son rythme
il y a des il y a des poussées dans un
sens un peu dans l'autre aujourd'hui il
y avait un peu moins de monde on va voir
samedi et puis programmer sans doute des
choses derrière mais ça c'est ça une vie
propre si vous voulez ces mouvements
après les syndicats ils sortent dessus
là l'Inter syndicale
apparemment sans trop d'anni croches
ceux qui tentaient de déborder un peu le
mouvement ce sont un petit peu assagi la
grève reconductible pour l'instant elle
est elle est elle est mise de côté dans
les secteurs qui annonçaient etc bon
peut-être si tout ça va tout ça va
s'ajuster alors une impasse je sais pas
il y a un débat en parlement en cours on
va voir effectivement les conditions
d'un débat parlementaire serein sont pas
franchement réunis les stratégies des
uns et des autres sont pas forcément
d'ailleurs dirigés vers vers un débat
serein et un accord il faut dire aussi
qu'on paye quand même
quelques années allez soyons généreux
parce qu'on pourrait parler de décennies
de d'irresponsabilité parlementaire
enfin dernière régime qui est devenu
présidentialisme à un point tellement
caricatural que demander aux à la
représentation parlementaire d'être
responsable c'est presque anachronique
ben ils ont pris l'habitude de nos
servir à rien que bon on pourrait dire
qu'il y a une occasion à saisir Benjamin
une occasion à saisir et malgré tout
aujourd'hui vous avez un parlement qui
fonctionne selon des canons un peu plus
traditionnels parce qu'en réalité en
effet depuis le quinquennat on a des
majoritaires absolues qui plus est la
structuration des parties parce que en
effet il y avait des blocs
présidentielles majoritaires mais il y
avait quand même des contre-pouvoirs au
sein du parti or aujourd'hui bien les
partis sont réduits comme peau de
chagrin et vous avez évidemment une
forme de dicte présidentielle qui
contrôle la majorité néanmoins là on a
quelque chose de nouveau ensuite sur ce
qui se passe ou Parlement ça s'appelle
de l'obstruction oui c'est ça c'est pas
nouveau ça c'est extrêmement possible
des milliers
d'air mais bon vous regardez toutes les
réformes des règlements de l'Assemblée
nationale et du Sénat depuis les années
80 toutes les réformes quasiment avaient
pour objectif de juguler l'obstruction
c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
classique il y a quand même des
singularités c'est pas le nombre
d'amendements 20000 je rappelle la
réforme d'EDF en 2006 130 000 à l'époque
souvenez-vous de Jean-Louis Debré qui
met en scène les 130 000 amendements sur
son bureau et vous avez à ce moment-là
malgré tout une ambiance bon enfant je
vous invite à reprendre les débats vous
avez une opposition qui arrive avec des
maillots de rugby pour montrer qu'elle
va lutter vous avez une majorité qui
arrive avec des tortues qui se baladent
avec des tortues pour expliquer que et
bien l'opposition fait n'importe quoi il
y a en effet un blocage c'est pas
actuelle exactement le blocage il est
entre guillemets traditionnel il s'agit
de bloquer la machine pour laisser la
mayonnaise monter dans la rue c'est très
classique ce qui est assez nouveau c'est
en effet que là il y a des tensions qui
sont réelles qui sont pas mimées elles
arrivent toujours mais là elles sont
continues et ça c'est relativement
inquiétant pour le débat parlementaire
alors Mathieu on va essayer d'analyser
toujours autour de ce mot l'impasse dans
une question beaucoup plus politique et
ils avaient de Bornel elle a fini par
lâcher du lest dimanche à la veille de
ces débats parlementaires pour l'instant
c'est son succès ben oui son succès pour
l'instant elle se retrouve dans une
drôle d'impasse vous le disiez parce
qu'elle est d'une certaine façon ferme
avec la rue Elisabeth borne ou souvenez
de cette petite phrase les 64 ans ne
sont pas négociables alors que c'est le
principal mot d'ordre de mobilisation
des syndicats et de l'autre côté un peu
contrainte à une forme d'ouverture avec
le Parlement ou en tout cas avec
certains groupes au Parlement ou en tout
cas avec un groupe au Parlement qui est
le groupe LR ce qui donne parfois le
sentiment quand on l'écoute d'un courant
alternatif jeudi dernier sur France 2
elle est un flexible elle dit bah c'est
comme ça elle explique que sa réforme et
puis trois jours plus tard dans le
Journal du Dimanche une petite phrase
nous allons bouger la sortie de trois
gestes trois atouts sortis de sa manche
alors d'abord la possibilité pour ceux
qui ont commencé à travailler entre 20
et 21 ans de partir au bout de 43 années
de cotisations donc à 63 ans 64 la mise
en place d'un bilan d'étape la fameuse
clause revoyure en 2027 et puis
l'extension de l'index senior aux
entreprises de plus de 55 salariés et
non plus seulement à partir de 300 à
sortir éventuellement aussi de sanctions
financières à discuter au Parlement les
deux premiers gestes c'était des appels
appuyés au groupe LR qu'on avait fait
des points durs le dernier a une partie
de la gauche et une partie de sa
majorité qu'il a trouvé trop timorée sur
le sujet de l'emploi des seniors mais
elle a fait chou blanc sur toute la
ligne puisque dans une surenchère assez
ahurissante même faut le dire une frange
DLR continue de faire monter la pression
et les enchères quant au syndicat par la
voie de Laurent Berger il a répondu dès
le lendemain c'est-à-dire dès le lundi
des hier dans Les Echos ce ne sont pas
des rustines qui changeront un projet de
loi injuste et brutal alors pendant ces
débats parlementaires à ce qu'il peut y
avoir d'autres gestes de la première
ministre c'est compliqué c'est là que
les gens du comment parce que les
aménagements les entre mesures de
compensation tout ça finit par coûter
cher très cher trop cher pour l'exécutif
on rappelle qu'un tiers des recettes
attendues par le relèvement de l'âge
légal à 64 ans et l'accélération de la
loi Touraine a déjà été mangé j'allais
dire par les mesures d'aménagement et
puis certaines demandes comme je pense à
celle du député LR Aurélien Pradier par
exemple qui lui demande que dès qu'on
attriste cotisé un trimestre avant 20
ans mais on puisse bénéficier du
dispositif carrière longue on dit on
l'étend à tout ce que l'exécutif appelle
les petits boulots d'été notamment ça ça
coûte 10 milliards donc ça aurait raison
de de l'équilibre financier et recherché
du régime on rappelle en 2030 du coup le
gouvernement il est contraint de jouer à
la marge dans les marges le ministre du
Travail Olivier du soft a annoncé hier
dans Libération peut-être des gestes de
revalorisation de pension ou de
compensation pour les femmes qui seront
à discuter au Parlement mais c'est un
chemin étroit quand on rappelle en tout
cas le garde-fou fixé par l'Élysée pas
touche aux cotisations pas touche aux
pensions
comment ça peut finir si on essaye de se
projeter quelques scénarios c'est
compliqué parce que on est deviner trois
scénarios possibles mais il se termine
pas très très bien pour l'exécutif aucun
des trois le premier c'est celui qu'on
pourrait appeler du passage en force ou
du passage malgré la mobilisation que ça
soit par un 49-3 ou par un vote même
mais avec un texte qui ne bougerait plus
beaucoup malgré son rejet dans l'opinion
alors là on prendrait l'exécutif
prendrait le risque de polariser de
fracturer durablement le pays jusqu'à la
fin du quincada alimentant soit une
révolte sourde mais puissante qui ne
faciliterait pas la vie de de du pouvoir
et du prochain gouvernement pour ses
futurs réformes le second scénario soit
pas de majorité soit blocage du pays en
tout cas renoncement retrait de la
réforme dissolution c'est pas le plus
probable mais c'est un enchaînement des
faits qu'on ne peut pas non plus
complètement écarter la troisième c'est
un projet j'allais dire affaidi avec
peut-être un report de l'âge légal qui
de serait qu'à 63 ou 64 ou par le jeu en
tout cas de de l'entrée en vigueur de la
réforme ou de la clause revoyure voilà
ça serait un petit peu adouci entre
guillemets dans les faits mais ça ne
sites ça ne satisfait ni les finances du
régime de retraite ni le gouvernement ni
l'opinion et donc là aussi ça serait
caramba encore raté on va reprendre
quelques années de ces quelques-unes de
ces hypothèses alors ça le 249.3 comment
est-ce que vous l'avez évalué parce que
il a été utilisé plusieurs fois on l'a
on l'associe à un passage en force et le
mot qui revient le plus souvent c'est
presque devenu un cliché quel effet ça a
sur l'opinion et si on essaie de se
projeter quel effet ça pourrait avoir
sur l'opinion alors sur ce thème là des
retraites
c'est pareil c'est un outil technique
au service de du Parlement vous
rappeliez tout à l'heure que les
obstructions effectivement étaient
monnaies courantes le recours au 49-3 en
fait quand on regarde dans l'histoire
parlementaire effectivement il y a un
certain nombre de ministres qui ont fait
appel qui ont eu recours c'est très
c'est la technicienne je dirais pour les
pour les Français certes ça marque un
gouvernement c'est-à-dire que ça marque
une image un peu de de dureté de de
passage en force mais aussi de
détermination de volonté de réformer le
pays etc quand on regarde
notamment ce que pensent les Français
sur justement le débouché de cette
réforme il reste encore persuadé comme
au début un des
mouvements sociales et presque persuadé
que le gouvernement ira jusqu'au bout de
sa réforme à plus de 70% en fait donc
pour eux on n'est pas dans une impasse
pour eux on va continuer on y va et et
qui effectivement à utiliser le 49.3 et
de toute façon ça a déjà été plus ou
moins
annoncé ou en tout cas
dévoiler par un certain nombre
d'opposants donc il y a ce point là et
puis il y a le point aussi sur une
réforme indispensable je pense que les
Français ils sont une petite majorité
c'est pas très très important mais
qu'une persuadée qu'une réforme est
quand même nécessaire c'est pas le
moment mais elle était nécessaire donc
quelque part finalement même si un
recours à ce 49-3 et bien en tout cas à
l'heure actuelle dans l'opinion ça
semble il semble y avoir une certaine
résignation ou une certaine fatalité
disons est-ce que les quand vous
analysez
Jean-Marie Pernaut un mouvement en cours
donc on vous appuyant sur les
précédentes etc parfois on a un peu
l'impression qu'il soit est déjà écrite
que c'est un peu toujours le même
déroulé
dans les grandes lignes est-ce que vous
dites ça
ça écarte ça éloigne pas les surprises
possible effectivement là par exemple
moi quand j'ai vu venir cette première
grande manifestation je me suis dit que
ça ressemblait furieusement à 2010 c'est
un mouvement un peu crescendo après sa
stabilise après soit on a un petit
couvert le haut puis après vers le bas
et puis au bout d'un moment il y a une
forme de la tension syndicale arrive le
pouvoir politique dit son qu'il est
inébranlable et donc bon bah les gens
finissent par cela c'est et puis ça
s'effiloche il y a des secteurs qui
durent d'autres qui reprennent voilà et
c'est pas une fin très très bonne mais
aussi il faut quand même observer une
chose c'est qu'il y a toujours des
effets politiques de ces mouvements
sociaux alors je dis politique pas
forcément au sens partisan du terme mais
ce sont des moments d'intense
politisation dans la population c'est à
dire que les gens tout le monde parle
des retraites dans les bistrots dans les
commerces dans les rencontres de
voisinage on parle on parle de ça on
peut pas et c'est des moments ça laisse
des traces parce que c'est pas souvent
que les gens s'intéressent aux questions
qui les intéressent sont souvent on se
sur le politique parce qu'ils sont là
pour ça on va où on va pas voter une
fois tous les 5 ans mais bon c'est
l'affaire en gros de ces spécialistes
nos hommes politiques après tout ils
servent bien à ça sinon ces moments-là
les gens reprennent un peu le contrôle
ça serait beaucoup dire mais se
réapproprie quand même des enjeux qui
sont qui ont des effets sur leur vie
personnelle mais aussi sur leur
entourage les enfants la retraite ça
concerne tout le monde sur un enjeu qui
est quand même un enjeu civilisationnel
la question de la retraite c'est un
point très très dur je pense que
là-dessus il y a une sous-estimation de
la part du gouvernement de cette
question même s'il peut passer au
forceps parce que les institutions font
que il peut toujours utiliser une 49-3
s'il arrive pas à construire une
alliance parlementaire donc il y a
toujours moyen de s'en sortir après
c'est à quel coût quel est le coût de
cela alors benoitus l'a évoqué dans le
petit extrait que vous avez donné le
risque de la violence et je pense qu'il
faut quand même examiner ça très
sérieusement c'est la grande différence
par rapport à 2000 à 2010 c'est que on a
eu le mouvement des gilets jaunes
entre-temps et que
peuvent devenir les colères sociales ça
peut devenir très éruptif et là c'est
pas la stratégie des syndicats au
contraire ils ont ils ont pas peur entre
guillemets de ça non parce que pour
l'instant c'est quelque chose ils
tiennent le mouvement ils tiennent le
mouvement les manifs sont bien ordonnés
selon la tradition entre très
institutionnalisés mais l'entêtement à
ne pas bouger ce qui n'est pas
négociable enfin je parle pas des
petites provocations du président de la
République allant le jour de la première
manif en Espagne pour dire que il y a
que la culture qui compte ou là le ou la
littérature je sais plus enfin bon alors
qu'il y avait 2000 un million comme dans
les rues enfin il y a des provocations
qu'on aurait pu éviter enfin ça peut
cristalliser des colères et là on sait
pas ce que ça peut donner vous lui
intervenir oui pour pour rebondir ce que
sur ce que vous dites c'est vrai que
depuis l'élection présidentielle
l'intérêt pour l'actualité politique n'a
pas baissé alors même que en principe en
temps normal justement juste après une
élection on voit l'intérêt pour
l'actualité politique qui baisse et puis
on a un petit ronronnement dans
l'actualité là aujourd'hui c'est pas le
cas aujourd'hui on a un niveau d'intérêt
qui est extrêmement élevé chez les
Français et puis le deuxième point aussi
que je que je voulais souligner je pense
que cet intérêt pour la politique c'est
aussi un intérêt plus global sur les
questions de société je pense qu'on est
dans un monde un peu en bouleversement
en changement en transformation et je
pense que ce regrette aussi les Français
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on n'est pas eu un
débat sur le monde du travail le travail
puisqu'en fait c'est ça pourquoi on ne
veut pas rester plus longtemps à
travailler est-ce que c'est vraiment
parce qu'on n'est pas bien au travail ou
est-ce que c'est pour d'autres raisons
et là je crois aussi que c'est que c'est
dommage et que je pense que les Français
attendaient ce genre de départ
cette réforme elle tombe à un moment qui
est quand même très particulier on se
pose enfin la société française se pose
des questions sur le sens du travail
c'était peut-être pas le moment de
d'imposer de cette façon deux années
supplémentaires et on fera d'ailleurs un
débat sur la valeur travail et le sens
le sens de cette idée dans quelques
jours sur sur ce plateau il y a la
question Benjamin Morel de
j'allais dire d'une
clause d'un contrat de confiance que les
syndicats pourraient presque renouer
avec les Français à l'occasion d'un
mouvement comme celui-là est-ce qu'on
pourrait dire ça du Parlement aussi
peut-être potentiellement c'est à dire
que alors je parle sous le contrôle de
la sondeuse mais en effet il y a dans la
forme de polyphonie parlementaire grosso
modo une vie parlementaire en régime
hyper présidentiel excusez moi mais
c'est ennuyant à mourir vous avez un
homme qui décide et du coup bah la
politisation nous évidemment ça nous
intéresse mais pour les Français il y a
pas réellement dans le jeu là ce qui est
intéressant avec cette réforme c'est que
malgré tout il y a un enjeu au débat il
y a eu des enjeux lors des précédents
mois des moments où vous introduisez de
l'enjeu et ben vous créez de la
politisation et vous créez de la
participation regardez les Etats-Unis
rien à voir mais Trump Biden sa mobilise
les élections précédentes sont vrais
enjeux perçues ça de mobilise pas la
mobilisation la politisation suit
l'enjeu et pour revenir sur ce qui a été
dit écoutez Marine Le Pen hier assez
intéressant le parallèle qu'elle fait
avec 2005 parce que évidemment elle
compte capitaliser là dessus si jamais
cette réforme passe et c'est là que la
question 49 à peut être intéressantes si
cette réforme passe mais que le
sentiment c'est que la démocratie a été
volée et bien là il y a deux
possibilités soit je me suis politisé et
en me politisant j'y ai cru et j'ai
l'impression qu'on m'a volé la chose et
je considère que la politique ne peut
rien qu'en fait on va mentir et je me
dépolitise soit je considère que et bien
il faut être en colère et la Marine Le
Pen évidemment capitalisme le 49 alinéa
3 en lui-même c'est juste un alinéa d'un
article de la Constitution la manière
dont vous le politisez en revanche ces
différents que vont faire les syndicats
que va faire la nuque que va faire le RN
ils vont tenter de politiser 49 à na3
dont je vois mal comment aujourd'hui on
pourra se passer et si jamais le
politisme bien et bien à ce moment-là il
y a des conséquences Mathieu je mets
deux bémols c'est d'abord que les
organisations politiques comme les
organisations syndicales sont quand même
en totale décrépitude il faut le dire on
a un ton sexe
et puis les parties se vident de leurs
adhérents vous pouvez tous les prendre
il se regonfle parfois par la campagne
présidentielle et ensuite il se vide et
on n'a pas vu en tout cas sur les 10
dernières années ce sera peut-être très
différent cette fois-ci mais de
mouvement d'adhésion vers un parti pour
changer les choses une fois qu'on s'est
conscientisé lors d'une réforme qui a
été beaucoup débattue ça n'empêche pas
que les Français se sont discute soit
politisés s'affrontent en débattre voilà
et puis l'autre chose c'est la
traduction l'éventuelle traduction dans
les urnes derrière ou qui pourrait tirer
les marins du feu Benjamin c’était un
très bon exemple 2005 en 2005 ou des
gens ont l'impression que la démocratie
est volée et qui était lu en 2007
Nicolas Sarkozy Jean-Marie Le Pen fait
un des plus mauvais scores du Front
national de ces de ces 20 dernières
années donc ça ne bénéfique et puis
l'extrême gauche qui c'était aussi
beaucoup mobilisé en tout cas une partie
de la gauche contre contre le référendum
constitutionnel européen enfin le
traiter aussi titutionnel européen on
n'a pas du tout bénéficié donc il y a
pas d'effet mécanique de d'une grosse
contestation sociale
par la suite alors je voudrais vous
proposer une une réaction dans ce dans
ce débat celle de Gabriel Attal ministre
délégué
public alors c'était hier en ouverture
des débats à l'Assemblée
si
nous l'accum
ulera
prochaine année si nous ne faisons rien
dans ces conditions et pour éviter une
rupture de trésorerie il y aura dans les
années à venir des baisses de pension
comme on l'a vu il y a des années dans
des pays européens en synthèse voilà
très précisément pourquoi nous faisons
cette réforme pour pouvoir continuer à
garantir à chaque Français que pour les
années à venir oui il pourra compter sur
une retraite n'ayons pas peur de le dire
en matière de retraite mesdames et
messieurs les députés c'est une réforme
ou la faillite c'est ça la réalité de
notre système aujourd'hui
une réforme ou la faillite l'oral cet
argument qui est pas nouveau que qui est
souvent un argument traditionnel on va
dire de la droite est-ce que j'ai
l'impression qu'il infuse pas du tout ou
très peu dans l'opinion depuis des
semaines même si le gouvernement quelle
que soit les voies qu'il expriment voilà
le répète je crois qu'il y a ni la
faillite effectivement ni la question de
la dette il y a encore une dizaine
d'années la question de la dette était
très présente dans les
des citoyens c'est à dire que c'était
voilà quelque chose qu'il est préoccupé
la dette publique le remboursement de la
dette publique aujourd'hui elle est au
17e rang des préoccupations des Français
donc on est plus dans cette
passer par là absolument et puis encore
une fois je disais tout à l'heure on est
dans un monde en plein bouleversement en
pleine transformation qui peut dire dans
20 ans ce qui va se passer d'un point de
vue démographique d'un point de vue du
travail des seniors du travail
des plus jeunes etc donc effectivement
c'est c'est un peu compliqué de se de se
positionner sur ce créneau là sur l'idée
qu'effectivement c'est la réforme ou la
faillite sachant en effet que ce qui
préoccupe aujourd'hui les Français qui
les préoccupe je dirais de façon très
très aiguë c'est le pouvoir d'achat
avant tout aujourd'hui n'ont pas ça qui
est un peu paradoxal c'est à dire que
sont les français demandent des réformes
d'anticipation mais là ils ont ils sont
dans une telle situation de malaise
qu'en fait ils ne sont plus du tout dans
l'anticipation mais vraiment dans la
gestion du quotidien qui est extrêmement
compliqué notamment avec l'inflation le
prix de l'énergie etc j'en ai perdu on
pourrait
savoir gré au gouvernement de vouloir
sauver le régime de retraite par
répartition oui enfin vous disiez c'est
l'Italie depuis le début non quand la
réforme est annoncée c'est pas au nom
des déficits à attendre c'était pour
dégager des marges de Manor pour
relancer l'investissement dans les
domaines où la France doit investir
c'était l'idée de de baisser le poids
des pensions dans le revenu national
pour dégager des marges de manœuvre
ailleurs la situation du système n'a pas
été évoqué dans un premier temps voyant
que ça patine on a rapporté on a ramené
ça et on essaie de dramatiser la tube le
calcul de Gabriel Atta le 150 milliards
c'est qu'il ajoute le déficit en
supposant que demain le déficit soit 10
milliards annuels ce qui est pas vrai
parce qu'il est projeté sur 15 ans mais
il a il additionne tout le stock de
dettes que ça fabrique pas c'est c'est
une volonté de dramatiser le problème
qu'ils ont c'est que les gens n'y
croient pas parce que parce que il y a
ce que vous dites sur oui enfin quand il
y a besoin de dégager de l'argent on en
trouve et puis et puis que c'est pas
vrai le système para répartition n'est
plus en danger il y a eu enfin Laurent
Berger l'explique toujours très bien en
disant c'est pour ça qu'il y a eu les
réformes en 2010 c'est pour ça qu'il y a
eu des réformes la réforme Touraine
c'est justement pour veiller le système
par répartition son gros avantage c'est
que justement on peut le gérer on peut
jouer sur un certain nombre de
paramètres au départ ça a été conçu
comme ça on pouvait jouer sur les
cotisations pour y jouer sur les durées
de cotisation sur leur montant etc donc
c'est un système qui se pilote donc
l'idée que le régime va sombrer
s'effondrer enfin tout ça c'est une
dramatisation qui patine complètement
dans le vide surtout que là quand même
il y a quelque chose qui est c'est qu'il
y a un front syndical qui tient le même
discours vous disiez tout à l'heure les
syndicats et que ça avaient mais
d'accord mais enfin les syndicats ils
mettent plus de 2 millions de personnes
dans les rues qui en France aujourd'hui
peut mettre de millions de personnes
dans les rues mais pas avec une cote de
confiance
le taux de syndicalisation est faible en
je suis pas le dernier à le relever mais
il y a pas qui sont pas les vainqueurs
avec un mot d'ordre assez simple parce
que c'est effectivement les 64 ans qui
qui passent pas
lorsque il produisent une analyse qu'il
le disent ensemble parce que c'est quand
même pas toujours et que ils offrent un
cadre d'action qui convient qui est
institutionnalisé dans lesquels les gens
se retrouvent bah les gens descendent
dans la rue donc si vous voulez je
prononcerai pas le diagnostic de leur
mort trop vite même si je fais un
bouquin pour ça bon critiquer le
syndicaliste d'aujourd'hui en disant
qu'il faudrait qu'il bouge mais enfin il
y a de la ressource pour peu qu'il le
fasse ensemble qu'ils disent des choses
qui apparaissent relativement sensé
c'est des acteurs quand même de la
démocratie qu'il faut pas et pas
seulement de la démocratie sociale même
s'ils utilisent eux-mêmes ce terme je
crois que c'est des acteurs de la
démocratie tout court qu'il faudrait
peut-être pas trop vite d'évaluer et
c'est pour ça que ce conflit cette
période elle est passionnante parce que
c'est c'est aussi voilà si les syndicats
réussissent à faire plier ou céder le
gouvernements forcément on peut imaginer
que leur code de d'adhésion de confiance
va remonter puisque les Français ils ont
ah bah oui ça ça peut servir à quelque
chose finalement et c'est le cas après
quelques quelques échecs précédents je
voudrais qu'on fait un petit focus sur
le les LR on en a évidemment déjà parlé
mais ce qui est pas si simple quand on
essaye de faire plaisir c'est qu'ils
sont pas toujours d'accord entre non
plus et écoutez Aurélien Pradier qui lui
est opposé à la mesure d'âge il le
rappelait ce matin sur notre antenne et
puis ensuite eriki qui demande plus
d'unités au sein du parti
moi j'ai une position qui n'a pas varié
alors je sais essuyer pendant quelques
semaines le mépris la condescendance de
tous ceux qui font mettre pression pour
que nous sédions au gouvernement que
nous acceptions que ça suffit on a assez
défendu assez obtenu de choses mais moi
je ne le prends pas moi je dénonce
toutes les attitudes qui sont contraires
à l'unité au rassemblement de notre
famille politique
nous sommes dans un moment difficile
difficile pour pour les Français et cela
nécessite de de mesurer chaque fois
c'est ces points de vue ces prises de
parole
Benjamin qu'est-ce qui se passe en ce
moment au conte on compte partie par
partie les députés qui potentiellement
peuvent voter voter cette réforme alors
on compte à la Nupe ça posera pas de
problème entre guillemets on voit à peu
près comment les députés vont voter on
compte également au RN ça ne posera pas
de problème dans la majorité c'est un
peu plus compliqué et c'est un problème
pour le gouvernement parce que quand
vous avez une majorité qui commence à se
diviser je l'évoquais tout à l'heure
c'est un problème mais la réalité c'est
qu'il y a pas de groupe LR il y en a
administrativement évidemment mais il y
a pas de groupe LR et c'est l'erreur
peut-être magistrale en termes de
stratégie parlementaire du gouvernement
la première grande concession celle qui
aurait peut-être permis de démobiliser
un petit peu elle a été faite en amont
de la réforme quand les Abed dit non pas
65 64 ans elle a pour quel objectif
cette concession d'acheter le groupe LR
il y a pas de groupe Air Éric utile n'a
pas d'autorité sur son groupe et donc ce
faisant ça tire quand même dans tous les
sens ou parliez du JDD de ce week-end
quelle est la volonté d'Elizabeth borne
d'acheter l'air nouvelle erreur parce
que encore une fois ça ne marche pas
vous avez des députés qui craignent une
dissolution ou qui visent 2027 ils ont
des remontées du terrain qui lui disent
qu'il leur disent ne votez pas cette
réforme Éric Ciotti n'a pas les moyens
de les contraintes vous avez des
logiques internes aux parties Aurélien
Pradier Xavier Bertrand etc aurait
absolument aucune autorité sur eux pas
même Olivier marlex et donc ce faisant
aujourd'hui aller chercher LR et
probablement une erreur stratégique par
ailleurs le gouvernement a commis une
autre erreur c'est que à travers le
PLFSS il peut pas faire beaucoup de
concession le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale c'est
un texte uniquement financier toutes les
concessions sur l'index seniors sur la
pénibilité ça peut pas figurer dans le
texte donc quand vous voulez aller
chercher un député LR c'est concessions
là c'est un tiens vaut mieux que de tu
l'auras parce qu'en réalité ça viendra
dans un autre texte extravail de texte
en tâche etc ça ne viendra pas tout de
suite donc ce n'est pas efficace donc là
aujourd'hui pour le gouvernement aller
chercher ses députés bah c'est pas peine
perdue mais c'est compliqué Mathieu la
seule solution qu'ils ont pourtant parce
que sinon le projet n'est pas adopté et
c'est vrai qu'il risque tient pas ses
troupes tient-il même ses convictions
souvenez-vous que lorsqu'il s'est
présenté la présidence de LR nos 11
décembre dernier c'était pas il y a 100
ans il défendait dans son projet la
retraite à 65 ans et un allongement de
la durée de cotisation de 43 à 45 ans
on va pour terminer il nous reste quoi
les 5 minutes parler de la mobilisation
de la jeunesse élément évidemment
important dans l'équation de ces
prochains jours je propose d'écouter la
présidente de lunès qui était ce matin à
fac de Tolbiac aujourd'hui
de faire la queue dans descriptions
alimentaires pour se nourrir et ce qu'on
veut absolument pas c'est à 67 ans
rebelote continue à faire la queue dans
des banques alimentaires pour pouvoir
manger à la fin du mois et donc c'est
pour ça que les jeunes sont mobilisés
aujourd'hui et qui rejoindront
l'ensemble des cortèges à travers la
France pour faire entendre la voix de la
jeunesse alors Salvin si on rentre un
petit peu plus là dans le détail des des
enquêtes d'opinion sur la mobilisation
des Français contre cette réforme des
des retraites les jeunes y sont plus
moins mobilisés au même niveau que les
autres
tranches d'âge alors ceux qui sont le
plus en soutien de la réforme ce sont
les 65 ans et plus ça c'est c'est clair
donc c'est ceux qui sont à la retraite
aujourd'hui
c'est pas concerné par la réforme
exactement ça bouge quand même chez les
retraités un peu enfin j'ai plus ça
reste quand même c'est pour ça que tout
à l'heure on disait il y a quand même
une certaine stabilité de l'opinion sur
ces sujets ça bouge de deux trois points
mais bon voilà c'est pas c'est pas
massif ce qui la rejette le plus cette
réforme ce sont les 50-64 ans c'est à
dire ce finalement qui vont être
vraiment impactés par
cette réforme ceux qui s'était déjà fait
un certain nombre de projets qui avaient
déjà fait un certain nombre de projet
qui avait déjà anticipé etc les jeunes
finalement donc je dirais les parce que
tout dépend à partir de quel âge vous
êtes jeune donc en toute 50 ans donc les
18-34 ans ce sont pas ceux qui sont le
plus en rejet de la de la réforme des
retraites au contrat ils sont même très
légèrement au dessus des 35 50 ans par
exemple vous voyez ils sont à peu près
32% 32 35% à soutenir la réforme des
retraites donc on peut pas dire que
c'est une mobilisation particulièrement
jeune on voit effectivement que que dans
les médias et l'opposition ils essaient
en effet de de de d'utiliser ce levier
là de dire on a la jeunesse avec nous et
puis effectivement il y a les grèves
dans des dans des lycées on l'a vu des
manifestations de lycéens mais dans la
réalité exactement le nombre de litres
quand on interroge un échantillon
représentatif de français en effet ce
sont pas les jeunes qui sont les
premiers soutiens Jean-Marie Pernaut
historiquement là aussi ça peut faire
basculer un mouvement l'entrée des
étudiants parce que c'est la grande
hantise des pouvoirs du poivre du
pouvoir politique aujourd'hui parce que
il y a deux il y a deux deux problèmes
et un troisième le premier c'est la
grève ce qu'on a commencé par là on va
pas y revenir le deuxième c'est la
jeunesse si la jeunesse rentre vraiment
massivement dans le mouvement alors là
c'est du CPE 2006 on contrôle plus rien
on est obligé de retirer en catastrophe
etc parce que quand l'hélice essorent
c'est c'est ça devient plus contrôlable
donc là il y a ça alors après il y a
moins pour observer un peu les
manifestations il y a quand même pas mal
de jeunes mais je pense comme vous
semble que je suis pas sûr qu'il sorte
vraiment massivement sur la question des
retraites enfin d'une certaine manière
c'est un petit peu rassurant parce que
s'il y a 14 ans leur souci principal
était la retraite ça serait quand même
pas un très bon signe pour le pays je
crois pas que ça soit en 2006 c'était
sur le contrat de travail qui était
offert à des jeunes rentrant sur le
marché du travail donc là ils étaient
très directement impactés c'était une
mesure extrêmement discriminatoire à
leur égard donc la réaction a été
extrêmement vive là malgré tout moi je
trouve que les il y a pas mal de jeunes
dans les manifs les cortèges sont plus
jeunes que les effectifs syndicaux ça
c'est clair euh
mais effectivement c'est c'est pas
évident que les jeunes rentrent dans
l'action le troisième scénario qui
pourrait faire bouger vraiment les
choses et du coup on a rien arriverait
une crise politique c'est la question de
la violence que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure c'est que s'il y a une perte de
contrôle et que il y a des formes
radicales qui prennent le relais sur le
thème bah toute façon rien ne marche la
démocratie il dit qu'il a été élu pour
faire ça il n'a pas été élu pour faire
ça il fait
syndicats les manifs gentils derrière
les banderoles ça sert à rien etc et de
toute façon il s'en foutent enfin bref
vous voyez le type de de discours qui
peut et là ça ne jouerait que sur des
minorités mais des minorités qui peuvent
être actives les gilets jaunes ont un
petit peu montré le chemin de ce qui est
possible si on respecte pas les codes
classiques de la protestation collective
donc voilà c'est je crois que avec ça
c'est les trois facteurs qui peuvent
vraiment modifier le paysage le reste
appartient aux champs politiques les
crises majorité etc bon moi je suis un
peu comme vous je crois pas beaucoup à
la solution parlementaire enfin je pense
que on ira au 49-3 parce que le reste
est assez quand même difficile à
organiser si on vous entend bien mais
bon et puis voilà après quel effet ça
aura dans l'opinion comment ça va se
payer dans les urnes 6 mois un an trois
ans plus tard c'est je crois que vous
aurez l'occasion de recommencer
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce premier débat genre je
rappelle le titre de votre livre vous
l'avez évoqué le syndicalisme d'après
qui est publié aux éditions du détour